lassen sie uns jetzt gemeinsam in die
ukraine gehen zu einem der bürgermeister
die all dieses leid im moment mit
ansehen müssen es passiert
beispielsweise habe ich gerade gesagt in
cernys in dieser stadt in der ukraine
dort sind wir mit dem bürgermeister
verbunden mit wladislaw ad schenk und in
seiner stadt sieht aktuell herr lindner
unter anderem so aus seit tagen heftige
raketeneinschläge bombardements bei ihm
die menschen wollen nur raus aus seiner
stadt und wir begrüßen ihn ladislav ad
rosenke hierbei bildschirm guten tag
herr trozenko
guten tag können sie uns ein bild
schildern bei mir der finanzminister
deutschlands christian lindner können
sie uns ein bild schildern wie es
aktuell in ihrer stadt aussieht
maschinist
unter der straße
befindet sich jetzt unter schrecklichen
bombenangriffen von
23 bis 26
august geben 41 1741 das war unser
täglicher bombenangriffe im laufe der
zweiten weltkrieg unsere stadt war
komplett vom erdboden zerstört
ausgelöscht und heute war hier passiert
russland will
das was damals passiert ist noch einmal
wiederholen und sogar noch mehr
menschen was sie gerade erfahren sind
aggressivste bombenangriff
tagtäglich
werden massenhaft
jeder geworfen tausende der wohnungen
nutzen
mehrstöckige häuser werden zerstört
also dass möglichen arten
verboten
[Musik]
davon so gestreut
nach diesen aggressiven bombardements
auf die stadt ja nie gewünscht
waren mehr als 40
einfach friedliche menschen getötet so
wollny
muss das mal hier heute erfahren
sehr groß beginnen und sie wurde nur
dass so was wie einfach reduziert
bezeichnen können genozid
griechischen volkes
befindet sich an der grenze zu russland
und auch so bloß nicht hier wohnen auch
die ethnischen russen und auch durch
menschen ausbilden
auch meine frau ist eine russin hat
rosi schildern das mit drastischen
worten aussprechen von genozid dort bei
ihnen in der stadt dort im
nordwesten der ukraine können sie
aktuell sagen wir haben gerade gemeinsam
darüber diskutiert was die
bundesregierung tun kann ob sie alles
tut was möglich ist ob der westen alles
tun haben sie in ganz konkreten wunsch
im moment an den westen an europa
ich habe einen ganz einfachen wunsch an
gerade europäerinnen und dabei erinnert
euch an das was im laufe der zweiten
weltkrieg geschehen ist glaubt nicht
dass putin stehen bleibt in der ukraine
gute der hitler des einundzwanzigsten
jahren es gibt keine garantien
die europäerinnen haben keine
garantieren dass putin in der ukraine
halt macht deshalb wenden wir uns an
deutschland
die moderne ausstattung moderne waffen
bereitstellen damit wir über uns selber
schützen können
deutschland soll auch die initiative
ergreifen
zusammen mit anderen raten staaten den
himmel und der ukraine schlüssen es ist
sehr wichtig
außerdem
sind sehr effektiv und der noch heute
immer noch die europäer russischen gas
und russisches
einmal die antwort des finanzministers
christian lindner wir kennen die
forderungen aus der ukraine die heute
auch genau so der ukrainische präsident
zielinski noch mal formuliert hat unter
anderem flugverbotszone die die nato
sagt dazu ganz klar nein die
bundesregierung sagt ganz klar nein die
bundesregierung sagt aber das haben sie
gerade getan auch noch mal ja zu
weiteren waffenlieferung ihre worte an
herrn entree schenkung ja ich bin
zutiefst berührt wladimir was sie
erdulden müssen welches leid sie sehen
in diesen zeiten kann man zunächst ihnen
einfach nur salutieren für diesen
unbeschreiblichen und diese tapferkeit
dass sie
dort für ihr leben für ihr land und ihre
freiheit kämpfen
und ich will ihnen sagen dass wir das
nichtvergessen auch wenn hoffentlich
bald die kriegshandlungen beendet sind
dann werden wir auch danach an ihrer
seite sein was wir tun können
unternehmen wir also die lieferung von
modernen waffen aus europa aus nato
staaten und aus deutschlands läuft ja
nicht alle waffen haben wir selbst als
deutsche jetzt dürfen wir uns nicht
überschätzen wir sind ja gerade selber
dabei wieder unsere verteidigung zu
stärken und wir glauben dass wir am
wirksamsten einen beitrag leisten können
indem wir die russische kriegskasse
trockenlegen das war die zentralbank die
russische wirtschaft ist dabei zu
kollabieren
und hier werden wir unsere anstrengungen
noch vergrößern damit putin einen preis
zahlt und nicht länger durchhalten kann
die wollen dass hier weiter diskutieren
herr trozenko danke ihnen ganz herzlich
und von uns alles gute in ihre stadt zu
ihren bürgern
danke ihnen herr schenkungen aus deiner
können
für die aufmerksamkeit wie bitte
damit sie verstehen wie sie tragen auch
ein teil der verantwortung für die
verbrechen die russland gerade er begeht
in der ukraine ohne so in der ganzen
stadt
russland versucht uns zu zerstören und
ja die besorgnis reicht nicht hälfte
ukraine und ukrainerinnen
danke für ihre worte hatte schenk und
dieser vorwurf der gilt uns allen gilt
nicht ihnen persönlicher lindner der
gilt der bundesregierung aber uns allen
im westen dass wir eben noch nicht ganz
tun was möglich wäre kommen wir konkret
auf dieses embargo zu sprechen dass auch
der bürgermeister dort gerade
angesprochen hat von cerny das ist ja
auch eine forderung die von zellen ski
aktuell kommt warum verzichtet er nicht
sofort auf alles weil das würde sofort
den geldzufluss stören die kriegskasse
leer machen in russland statt dessen
müssen wir uns ja schon den schuh
anziehen dass wir sagen ja im moment
finanzieren wir 200 millionen euro am
tag den putin krieg mit
die kriegskasse also die notenbank ist
ja unter einem schweren embargo das
bedeutet die lieferungen von öl und gas
und kohle nach europa fließt eben nicht
automatisch in seine kriegshandlungen
wir müssten jetzt verantwortlich
entscheiden und deshalb sollte man auch
die
entscheidungsgründe offen legen dann
können sich auch die bürgerinnen und
bürger ihre zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
ein bild machen verzichten wir auf gas
und öl und kohle lieferungen aus
russland
bedeutet das dass die preise in
westeuropa und der welt dramatisch
steigen werden aufgrund der erwartbaren
knappen das wissen alle deutschen ganz
kurz dazwischen wir haben mit hilfe der
bild am sonntag am wochenende ja genau
danach gefragt die mehrheit der
deutschen überwältigende mehrheit sagt
ja sofort stoppen die gaslieferung und
die überwältigende mehrheit der
befragten sagt aber auch nein wir wollen
keine steigende preise akzeptieren und
ich als mitglied der bundesregierung
muss entscheiden weil auf der einen
seite sehe ich die solidarität der
menschen die ich mit der ukraine teile
gestern noch mit der ukrainischen
wirtschaftsministerin getextet der im
persönlichen austausch stehe die mich
anfang februar hier in berlin noch
besucht hat als man sich nicht hat
vorstellen können welche
schockierende und grauenvolle
entwicklung die geschichte hat nehmen
können also auf der einen seite die
solidarität auf der anderen seite die
folgen ich will dass nur kurz noch mal
ausführen damit die menschen sich ein
bild machen können die preise gehen nach
oben und wir können selbst wenn wir das
geld einsetzen
physikalisch nicht einfach kohle und gas
und öl kauft man muss ja physikalisch in
der materiellen realität die rohstoffe
von woanders erst nach deutschland
bekommen dh auf eine mittlere sicht
nicht jetzt nicht im sommer aber
vielleicht im nächsten herbst und winter
hätten der versorgungsengpässe und
müssten sehr einschneidende maßnahmen
diskutieren und deshalb ist meine
einschätzung stand heute
wir sollten unsere eigene
durchhaltefähigkeit nicht einschränken
wirsol ihren russland politisch
wirtschaftlich finanziell und das halten
wir
länger durch als putin unsere
durchhaltefähigkeit aufgrund eben unsere
eingeschränkten rohstoffversorgung
könnte negativ beeinträchtigt werden
wenn wir von uns aus ein embargo
verhängen ich
glaube dass wir hier einfach rational
entscheiden müssen was trifft putin
mittelfristig am stärksten und was
leistet deshalb auch den größten beitrag
sein macht appetit einzuschränken und
ihn in die schranken zu verweisen
das völkerrecht durchsetzt wir haben da
den längeren atem sagen sie nur wir
sehen wie es nach elf tagen krieg in der
ukraine aussieht das heißt das sind nur
elf tage da reden wir über
vergleichsweise kurze zeiträume über
eine million menschen auf der flucht
wahrscheinlich tausende tote
mittlerweile im land das zeigen die
bilder unter
zerstörte völlig dem erdboden
gleichgemacht steht das heißt da läuft
die zeit natürlich ab da hilft ein
längerer atem aktuell an der stelle
nicht können wir da so rational
argumentieren können wir da zwischen
über gaspreise dürfen wir überhaupt über
gaspreise rohölpreise reden oder
überwiegt da einfach die moralische
verpflichtung in diesen stunden in
diesen tagen wenn ein embargo bei gas öl
und kohle etwas an der konkreten
situation heute in der ukraine
verändern würde dann wäre ich für ein
embargo und
das glauben sie aber nicht wenn man
jetzt den gashahn abdrehen würde würde
es keinen moment helfen den menschen in
der ukraine davon sind nicht heute dann
ist die nächste moralische frage und
auch die ist wahnsinnig kompliziert für
uns alle ja zu beantworten die eines
nato ein evans in diesen krieg der
bürgermeister von cerny hat das auch
gerade noch mal formuliert diese
flugverbotszone die ja bedeutet die nato
wäre drin in diesem konflikt wahnsinnig
schwere abwägung wir beziehen uns auf
den nato vertrag der ganz klar sagt die
ukraine ist außerhalb der nato deswegen
müssen dürfen sollen wir nicht in diesem
fall aber können wir so sehr auf dieses
vertragsdetails schauen wenn dort ein
wie er sagt genozid stattfindet nein wir
müssen nicht auf dieses vertrags detail
schauen es ist natürlich möglich auch
außerhalb des territoriums der nato
tätig zu werden wenn alle nato
vertragsstaaten das wollen aber auch da
erlaube ich mir einfach die frage weil
ich bin jetzt mitglied der
bundesregierung
ich habe meinen amtseid geschworen auch
schaden vom deutschen volk abzuwenden
und ich kann nicht kurzfristig nach
meinem eigenen herzens entscheiden
sondern ich muss entscheiden in der
verantwortung für unser land insgesamt
in der verantwortung auch für das was
folgen könnte eine flugverbotszone die
die nato in der ukraine durchsetzen
würde bedeutet in der konsequenz
dass bundeswehr eurofighter mit
deutschen pilotinnen und piloten oder
amerikanische kampfflugzeuge auf
russische flugzeuge schießen
das wollen wir alle nicht und trotzdem
fragen wir uns wie lange wir alle das
ertragen aber bei an ball dann aus der
ukraine aber was folgt daraus wenn ein
deutsches kampfflugzeug auf ein
russisches schießt dann ein deutscher
eurofighter schießt ein russisches
flugzeug ab was folgt als nächstes
welche eskalation kommt dann dann
bewegen wir uns in einer
eskalationsstufe einer militärischen
auseinandersetzung
auch zwischen russland und der nato auch
zwischen russland und deutschland ist
dass man halt fürchterliches dilemma
dass sie dass das ist völlig zu recht
ablehnen ausschließen bis zuletzt dass
das was niemand will dass sie genau das
so aussprechen aber auf der anderen
seite jemanden haben der all das nicht
ausschließt sondern genau damit
wladimir putin muss wissen wenn er
seinerseits
territorium der nato eingreift wenn er
etwa die baltischen staaten bedroht das
dort wir als nato-staaten natürlich
reagieren würden und deshalb
trotz aller unberechenbarkeit von putin
weil er um die damit verbundenen
konsequenzen weiß
glaube ich nicht daran dass wir damit
konfrontiert werden denn die dann
folgende auseinandersetzung
hat potenziell hat potenziell eine
gefahr die die ganze zivilisation
bedrohen ein atomkrieg
bei schwer hat ja bereits davon
gesprochen dass er seine nuklearwaffen
in alarmbereitschaft gesetzt hat oder
zumindest taktischen nuklearwaffen
ich fand es übrigens ausgesprochen weise
und klug dass die vereinigten staaten
von amerika nicht darauf reagiert haben
indem sie ihre nuklearwaffen potenzial
eine höhere alarmstufe versetzt haben
zeichen von stärke das war ein zeichen
von nervenstärke und das nicht eine
eskalation
fortgesetzt werden soll bei der am ende
die
die die konsequenz ein nuklearer
schlagabtausch sein könnte und deshalb
ich will es noch mal sagen es ist keine
keine mangelnde solidarität mit der
ukraine wir tun alles was in unserer
macht steht wirklich und wüsste ich
weiteres außer sanktionen und
humanitärer und militärische
unterstützung im sinne von
waffenlieferungen dann könnte man mit
mir darüber sprechen aber aus diesen
grauenvollen krieg einen noch größeren
krieg zu machen wird nicht leid
reduzieren sie haben ganz ehrlich
beantwortet und auch mit dem verweis auf
ihren amtseid nämlich dass sie sich eben
natürlich den deutschen volk
verpflichtet fühlen und gleichzeitig
werden wir diese bilder natürlich nicht
los wir werden jeden bill jeden tag
wahrscheinlich noch grausamere bilder
ertragen müssen und das leid der ukraine
wird jeden tag grausam habe gibt es
diesen punkt wo sie eine entscheidung
treffen könnten wie das in den 90er
jahren beim kosovo krieg passiert ist wo
man dann eben sagt das ist eigentlich
außerhalb unserer nato sphäre und doch
sind wir gezwungen etwas zu tun weil
dort eben ein völkermord für das frühere
jugoslawien das war ein bürgerkrieg
wir haben es jetzt zu tun mit einer
nuklear gerüsteten macht wie russland
was haben sie sind familienvater so ist
es
welche abwägung treffen sie und ich
glaube wir haben harte maßnahmen
beschlossen bei den sanktionen die haben
auswirkungen auf uns auf die
energiepreise wir haben eine
jahrzehntelange
politische grundhaltung in deutschland
verändert wir liefern waffen in ein
krisengebiet
aber
ich halte es nicht für verantwortbar
dass wir diesen krieg noch größer machen
und daraus auf eine einer
auseinandersetzung zwischen nato und
russland machen ich sehe übrigens auch
nicht um es klar zu sagen das ist nicht
die meinung von christian lindner
ich sehe nicht dass es im kreis der der
nato-verbündeten diese haltung gibt die
gemeinsame position ist wir isolieren
russland politisch wirtschaftlich und
finanziell wir unterstützen die ukraine
mit allem was wir können aber wir treten
nicht ein in einem krieg mit russland
selbst